a source tells e.t alec baldwin is
devastated following the fatal
accidental shooting on the set of his
film rust the actor fired the prop gun
that was inadvertently loaded with a
live round that struck and killed
cinematographer helena hutchins and
hospitalized director joel zusa
we've had two people accidentally shot
on a movie set by a prop gun we need
help immediately
now e.t source says the actor is beside
himself quote he is incredibly
devastated and sick to his stomach over
what happened he is still processing
everything and dealing with a lot of
grief and shock
the source adds that alex's wife ellaria
baldwin is trying to be there for him in
the best way she can but even so quote
it is a heart-shattering situation for
everyone involved on saturday alec met
with helena's husband matt hutchins as
well as their nine-year-old son andros
for breakfast in santa fe matt tweeted a
tribute to his late wife on friday
posting this photo with their son and
writing in part quote helena inspired us
all with her passion and vision and her
legacy is too meaningful to encapsulate
in words
the sheriff's department in santa fe new
mexico confirmed to e.t on thursday
night that alec who stars in the film
and serves as co-producer was the one
who discharged the prop gun which led to
the fatal accident we were rehearsing
and it went off and i ran out we all ran
out also according to the police quote
this investigation remains open and
active no charges have been filed in
regard to this incident witnesses
continued to be interviewed by
detectives
so what went wrong e.t has obtained an
email sent by the union that covers prop
masters describing the shooting as quote
an accidental weapons discharge in which
quote a live single round was
accidentally fired on set by the
principal actor you know i'm very
concerned personally about how
something like this was able to occur
firearms expert stephen gatowski said
it's possible someone mixed up blank
rounds with live rounds physically the
difference between a blank round and a
live round is is very noticeable clearly
there must have been a serious breach in
safety protocols for this to have
happened on friday alec addressed the
onset accident on twitter writing quote
there are no words to convey my shock
and sadness regarding the tragic
accident that took the life of helena
hutchins a wife mother and deeply
admired colleague of ours he noted that
he's fully cooperating with the police
investigation to address how the tragedy
occurred
and on sunday joel who is still
recovering from his injuries spoke out
for the first time since the accidental
shooting in a statement with nbc news
quote i am gutted by the loss of my
friend and colleague helena she was kind
vibrant incredibly talented fought for
every inch and always pushed me to be
better my thoughts are with her family
at this most difficult time